cette vidéo extrêmement choquant
insoutenable et provoquant une
sidération infinie des images
abominables d' agression barbare paris
vendredi 15 janvier 18h30
le jeune youri s'apprête à rentrer chez
lui pour fêter son quinzième
anniversaire sur l'esplanade de
beaugrenelle dix individus cagoulés lui
tombe dessus
il est roué de coups tabassés pendant de
longues minutes et laissé pour mort mais
qui sont ces agresseurs pourquoi ont-ils
agi ainsi sa maman natalia sera avec
nous ce soir
elle va tenter de mettre la main sur
ceux qui s'en sont pris à son fils
merci d'être avec nous merci natalia
merci d'être là je vous sont déjà émules
et extrêmement triste déjà ce soir sept
ans comment vallori aujourd'hui dur il
va mieux
par contre par les moments c'est très
compliqué parce que c'est pas encore et
youri qu'on a connue est sorti du coma
il arriva à vous parler il arrive à
prononcer quelques mots
d'accord mais par contre et hilario pas
encore composer les phrasés s'exprimer
mais je vois qu'il ya beaucoup de
volonté à me dire quelque chose non vous
êtes venu avec le beau père de youri
merci d'être là alors c'est vrai que
vous deviez pas venir dit merci en tout
cas d'être avec notre voleur vous
exprimer soit votre prénom guin saga
scène merci beaucoup en tout cas d'être
là alors on va revenir son état il va
mieux il est sorti d'affaires
que disait médecins les médecins ils me
disent que le plus dur c'est passé
d'accord contre on a appris tout à
l'heure que demain il y aura encore une
opération l'accord de quoi opération des
yeux les yeux ayant été touchés ils sont
sortis des orbites et il va falloir
vivre demain ça en opération des yeux
j'avais été le voir vous le voyez vous
voyez ça vous lui il voit mais par
contre pour plus tard il faut le faire
maintenant d'accord sinon il risque de
d'avoir des pylônes ce qu'avaient ils
risquent d'avoir les problèmes
alors on dit le 15 janvier au soir quand
lloris se fait rouer de coups par une
bande d'individus
comment est-ce qu'on vous informe de
l'agression du riz vendredi soir
j'essaie dé joindre à mon fils deux fois
il m'a pas répondu
d'habitude ça nous arrive pas il me
répond où il me rappelle tout de suite
d'accord ce soir là on dirait que j'ai
senti qu'il ya quelque chose qui se
passe il m'a pas répondu
je lui ai envoyé quelques textos
il m'a pas répondu non plus au troisième
fois le téléphone et le test sur
répondeur ensuite j'étais prévenue par
la police
la police elle a prévenu mme agnès
magnas il m'a prévenu
comme quoi que moi mon fils il s'est
fait agresser au moment où j'apprends
j'apprends en sable j'ai je sais pas
quoi dire je ne sais pas quoi faire par
contre on m'a demandé de venir vite et
tout de suite c'est ce que je fais
j'arrive
j'arrive à côté de monoprix et de
beaugrenelle sur dans le casier ma part
y est lancé à quartier bernon et passons
il ya un très grand centre commercial où
il ya vraiment plus normé monde
dans l'eau vous arrivé là bas j'arrive
là-bas la police elle me laisse pas
m'approcher
les pompiers n'ont plus il me laisse pas
rentrer d'un camion ils me disent que il
faut que j'autorise d'ingénierie à
l'hôpital par contre je peux pas aller
au bar ensuite je le demande je leur
promis qu' il n'y aura pas de problème
avec moi je leur promets que je vais
être forte pour monfils mais j'ai besoin
de le voir j'ai besoin de le soutenir et
j'ai besoin de lui parler au moment où
il me laisse quand même rentré d'un
camion pompier
là je retrouve mon fils vous pouvez pas
imaginer dans quel état c'est pas c'est
pas humain c'est quelque chose que c'est
pas choquant c'est horrible
vous pouvez pas imaginer qu'est ce
qu'ils ont fait avec mon enfant vous
voyez comme vous le retrouver et je les
retrouve
je les photos mais je les montrerai pas
non mais on veut pas les voir s'associer
à ce que c'est très grave ce qu'ils ont
fait avec mon enfant
ils l'ont même sans scanner je le voyais
qu'il va faire il va falloir opérer la
tête à tête elles étaient ouvertes
partout partout on voyait l'écran ouvert
c'est pour ça que ensuite j'ai lu parlé
j'ai dix jurés qu'est ce qui s'est passé
dis moi s'il te plaît qu'est ce que cela
vous fait il était conscient et
l'inconscient ces moments là je le
demande et dis moi qu'est ce que s'est
passé
même les bons bilans a donné qu'il est
conscient encore parce qu'il n'y avait
pas il y avait perdu beaucoup beaucoup
de sang il m'a demandé il m'a demandé de
le venger
il m'a demandé de les retrouver et quand
je lui dis aimer lloris ce qui t'as fait
ça pourquoi ils ont fait ça tu leur dois
quelque chose qu'est ce qui se passe
explique moi s'il te plaît en ce moment
la durée il me dit maman je les connais
pas je le connais pas je les connais pas
ne me laisse pas mourir s'il te plait je
te supplie fait au plus vite et ne me
laisse pas mourir moment vous pouvez
imaginer
en tant que maman qu'est ce que je
soutiens ces moments là mais j'ai rester
forte
je vais pas pleurer je lui dis jury
je te promets qu'on va s'en sortir
j'étais promène qu'on va les trouver y
aurait jeté promet que tu vas vivre tu
vas rester avec toi je sais que j'ai
jeté mes paroles
quelque part en l'air parce que c'est
mon mandat je savais pas est ce qu'on va
pouvoir sauver y aurait en arrivant à
l'hôpital il y avait la police avec nous
il y avait tous les médecins et quand
j'ai vu arriver plusieurs dents dans
l'endroit où ils avaient scanner je
savais qu'il ya quelque chose grave
qu'ils se passent par contre qu'en ce
moment même où il était agressif et le
médecin ils m'ont expliqué que c'est
tout à fait normal après les coups qu'il
a reçus
c'est à dire il était encore conscient
ce moment là il était conscient ce
moment là aussi mais il était assez
agressive ensuite les médecins ils m'ont
annoncé ce que j'attendais qu'il va
falloir opérer la nuit où on a passé à
attendre donc il est opéré et leur père
et tout de suite
et là l'opération elle durait jusqu'à 6
heures là maintenant
après il est ami d'un coma artificiel
parce que comme on m'a expliqué que
autrement on peut pas faire ça cet effet
pour cent bien et les timides en commun
et chaque jour on voyait surtout c'était
dimanche et lundi les pronostics et à
les interroger
parce que l'attention sauter on voyait
les machines on regardait comment ça
saute
comment ça baisse les médecins il venait
de temps en temps mais maintenant il
ils m'ont rassuré ils m'ont dit que le
pire est là il est derrière mais elle
sait qu'elle peut être on va retrouver
après il parle de quelles séquelles les
médecins pour l'instant pour l'instant
ils ne parlent pas donc là il va se
faire opérer des yeux demain parce que
plutôt ont fait mieux c'est hélas et
rouky qu'il peut supporter encore une
opération yomiuri cité cc quel type de
l'adolescent lloris est un garçon même
moi même aujourd'hui j'ai reçu un mail
de son ancien directeur de centre de
loisirs d
l'école g reçoit les mails il ça me
confirme que je ne sais pas que moi
qu'au moment je voyais mon fils bien
respectueux c'était un élève qui qui
travaillait bien qu'ils travaillaient
bien à l'école qui était souriant qui
était respectueux qui était obéissant à
la maison c'est vrai comme chaque à
chaque adolescent il avait du caractère
et j'espère qu'il y aura toujours
est-ce que vous savez aujourd'hui un peu
mieux ce qui s'est passé ou pas du tout
parce que j'ai vu beaucoup de choses
circulent et on va en parler
est ce que vous savez un peu mieux ce
qui s'est passé aujourd'hui ou pas on
sait beaucoup de choses
alors qu'est ce qui se dit paul
inquiètent on peut pas parler d'accord
mais on dit que c'est ce qu'on m'a dit
c'est que il ya eu des échauffourées
avec une autre bande un autre quartier
et que c'était une vengeance de cette
bande là qui avait été agressé il ya
quelques jours contre lui ou est ce que
c'est cette version que vous avez
également écouter en audi en eau dit
qu'il y avait quelque chose derrière ça
pourrait pas être content qu'ils les
connaissent et loué dur il m'a dit qu'il
ne connaît pas même tout à l'heure je le
demande est d'accord il les connaît pas
par contre qu'est ce que c'était
exactement je ne sais pas vous l'avez
senti nerveux ces derniers jours avant
l'agression bien senti qu'il était non
qu'ils sont et peut-être voilà on y est
en danger ou pas du tout non pas du tout
il n'y avait pas dit normal différence
juste une fin il a reçu un coup de fil à
cet art le soir d'accord ça en alliée à
la police aussi on n'a pas trop fait
attention parce que on lui a demandé
c'est quoi
qu'est ce qui se passe et lille n'en
sais rien c'est à saint bérain son beau
père qui l'a qu'il a répondu
finalement on ne sait pas exactement
qu'est ce que s'est passé ce soir là et
qui ce qui c'était et pourquoi c'était
mais je sais que très prochainement on
va apprendre qu'ils s'étaient et
pourquoi c'était par contre j'ai me
permets de rajouter que j'ai vu les
vidéos circulent et j'ai vu des vidéos
circulent et qui montre une autre
agression oui c'est ça il ya quelques
jours qui auraient été commis
par par la bombe de la bombe une bombe
dont la dette est limité
sur twitter il avait ça par contre à
aucun moment je voyais aurait déçu
d'accord en tant que maman si la police
elle me dit que votre fils il a frappé
quelqu'un je veux qu'il soit puni parce
que moi je pense pas qu'il y aurait là
fait ça je le connais très bien mon fils
mais c'est la police de faire leur
travail mais peu importe c'est par les
enfants et c'est pas de cette manière
qu'on règle quelque chose on est en 2021
on n'est pas dans les jeux vidéo bien
sûr on n'est pas dans on se jette pas
sur les gens comme ça on voulait les
images sont d'une violence c'est la
volonté film est vraiment si on ne peut
pas on ne peut pas on ne peut pas donner
aux enfants les bases d'éducation comme
ça on ne peut pas on ne peut pas se
permettre à demain ça peut être le fils
de madame monsieur dupont aujourd'hui
c'est youri ça peut être petit moustapha
omar ahmed
peu importe on ne peut pas on ne peut
pas donner les enfants faire ça il faut
interdire ça il faut arrêter cette
agression
c'est ce que c'est ce que je souhaite
pour tous les enfants je veux pas que on
est on est en france on est dans ce beau
pays
on peut pas se permettre de vivre comme
ça il faut pas leur donner éducation
comme ça alors aujourd'hui bien sûr
votre choix et c'est d'abord que youri
aille mieux celle ci c'est la première
chose bien entendu la deuxième chose
c'est ce que vous avez dit c'est que
vous voulez savoir qui sont ses
agresseurs pourquoi ils ont fait ça je
veux savoir pourquoi ils ont fait ça je
veux vraiment aller voir et les regarder
dans les yeux et demander pourquoi ils
ont fait ça avec mon enfant qu'est ce
qu'il a fait mon enfant qu'est ce qu'il
a fait je veux savoir ça il je veux
qu'ils sont j'arrive à voir les images
je l'avais je les connais par coeur
voyez moi que je les connais et ces
images là ils vont rester à vie avec moi
vous avez confiance en la justice ou
penser que dans la police pour ses
agresseurs vont être retrouvés avec le
soutien qu'on a eu ces derniers temps je
trouve que je laisse la police
judiciaire faire je disais rien jusqu'à
mercredi dernier
je parlais pas trop j'ai parlé à mon
entourage c'est vrai qu est-ce que c'est
vrai que cette affaire on n'était pas
vraiment au courant de cette histoire
elle et elle a immergé
si j'ose dire sur les réseaux sociaux ce
week-end vraiment parce qu'il ya cette
vidéo qui a été posté mais avant c'est
vrai qu'on avait entendu parler de cette
histoire mais on n'avait pas vu la vidéo
donc il y avait pas eu ce soulèvement
aussi nationale voilà qui fait que tout
le monde en a parlé que ces images ont
choqué toute la france j'ai déposé
plainte samedi
d'accord j'ai dit à la police que
j'attends un petit peu s'il y aura pas
de résultats je vais aller très loin
mais je laisserai pas ça comme ça qu'on
plusieurs affaires qui sont passés sans
suite j'ai dit ça à la police de
vaugirard
j'ai dit ça aux policiers de troisième
division
j'ai dit ça à tout le monde j'ai dit au
collège je dis partout et je le fais
j'ai le premier c'était le parisien
caroline a piqué la journaliste qui est
venu me voir à l'hôpital c'est moi qui
l'a demandé de publier cet article
et j'ai dit que je vais aller loin et je
m'arrêterai pas et je sais que
maintenant la police c'est vrai à paul
et cette passion de travail en scène on
sait beaucoup de choses vraiment
beaucoup de choses eux aussi la police
elle s'est beaucoup de choses par contre
il faut un tout petit peu du temps qui
fait le beau père de youri merci d'être
avec nous également
c'est incroyable ces images qu'on c'est
vous qui avez guessan au courant natalia
on était à la maison en e2 d'accord vous
étiez de la maison vous êtes
malheureusement je n'ai pas pu faire le
déplacement
bien sûr on à la petite maison qui est
un an et demi
courue dans quel état vous êtes
aujourd'hui guessan quand on n'est pas
ce que vous considériez youri comme
comme votre fils aujourd'hui quand vous
voyez ces images qu'on voyait l'état du
riz vous êtes dans quel état dans un
état vous êtes donc être quel état vous
dit j'ai envie de me venger
j'ai envie que justice soit faite j'ai
envie de je me sens impuissant je me
sens d'autant qu'elle est en sang en
fait quand on a vu moi personnellement
quand j'ai vu les images de la première
française natalia parce que moi j'étais
tellement touché j'étais vraiment
effondré quand j'ai vu les images
parce que c'était d'une violence
incroyable et n'a jamais vu ça j'y
croyais à braga qui a donné les deux
coups les derniers coups de marteau
c'est vraiment il était sûr qu'il a tué
un chien c'est ça qui est grave ça veut
dire s'il n'était pas sûr que la théorie
il part pas ils vont rajouter d'autres
coups il était inconscient et régiment
pas même sûr du coup grave comme ça
son corps y réagit plus parce qu'il
était inconscient mais malgré ça on
rajoute deux coups de marteau sur la
tête
c'était tellement violent aujourd'hui je
pense
il faut pas qu'on s'arrête sur un youri
city l'agression on sait très bien que
ça se passe souvent pas de tels aveux
dans une telle violence wepad et elvire
ans mais aujourd'hui je pense faut
réagir oui il faut que les agresseurs
soient punis il faut donner des leçons
les enquêteurs des mains quand ils vont
donner le verdict les punitions pour les
agresseurs il faut penser les messages
qui vont donner aux jeunes parce qu'on
parle d'une partie mineure des majeures
pour moi c'est des criminels mineurs
majeur c'est des criminels faut que ça
soit fini
on sait très bien qu'il ya une partie
qui sont majeurs qui a une partie qu'ils
sont mineurs ils ont fait le déplacement
il ya quatre kilomètres de trajet ça
veut dire ils étaient déterminés ils
sont partis pour qu'il y ait quelqu'un
c'est pas j'ai réagi m'a frappée je le
frappais et les
mais dans un état grave là ils sont
vraiment ils ont décédé ils ont planifié
leurs truites
ils ont fait le déplacement pour payer
quelqu'un sur la dalle de beaugrenelle
là aujourd'hui il faut vraiment réagir
si demain je sais pas moi la décision ce
sera quoi
nous on demande la peine maximale parce
que les jeunes s'ils vont se rendre
compte demain que tant que mineur je
peux faire ce que je veux
il n'y a pas grand chose je risque pas
grand chose il faut que ça soit pour une
fois pour toutes il faut régler cette
histoire urlee alors il ya une enquête
en cours un bien entendu on va voir
parce que c'est vrai qu'il ya d'autres
sons de cloches également sur les
réseaux sociaux il ya des gens qui a eu
qui disent qu'il y avait eu une
agression il ya quelques jours bien sûr
c'est pas et c'est pas du tout une
raison pour réagir ainsi aimer c'est
vrai style je suis fier c'est très
exactement comme c'est très grave ta
sont les images et je vous dire quoi
qu'il arrive quoi qu'il se soit passé
face à ces images sont inadmissibles et
ce comportement bien sûr doit être puni
et c'est ce que tout le monde a dit nous
ce qu'on espère aujourd'hui surtout
secure y aille mieux on espère que youri
va pouvoir rejouer au foot parce que je
sais qu'ils jouaient au foot c'était qui
va pouvoir rejouer au foot qui a pouvoir
revivre normalement ça c'est vraiment la
première chose on espère que vous allez
nous donner des nouvelles
et bien entendu on espère aussi que
toute la lumière sera faite sur cette
affaire et que les responsables et les
criminels sont calmées parce que et
c'est vrai qu'on soumet tous ce soir
tous ceux qui nous regardent
on est un petit frère qu'on a un grand
frère qu'on ait des enfants on se met
tous à la place de natalia et de vous
parce qu'aujourd'hui on se dit comment
on aurait réagi
mais même le voit déjà quand on regarde
les images de youri on a tous
l'impression que c'est quelqu'un de
notre famille on se dit comme on aurait
réagi pourquoi face à une telle violence
pourquoi
oui surtout pas pourquoi une telle
violence et cette volonté vraiment de
tuer comme vous l'avez dit barbarie et
imaginer aujourd'hui dans quel état
natal hier quand elle revoit ses images
quand elle revoit son fils à l'hôpital
c'est traumatisme que vous aurez
certainement la vie j'espère que vous
allez vous en remettre j'espère que
youri va s'en remettre
parce que là c'est vraiment les médecins
qui sont décembre amont les spécialistes
des autres niveaux et ça c'est sans sur
tous les niveaux les infirmières les
aides soignantes les médecins ils sont
vraiment adorables d'ateliers ce que
vous avez un dernier mot à dire ce soir
le dernier mot à dire concernant cette
histoire c'est que je veux vraiment
qu'on vit dans ce beau pays sans
agression qu'on est dieu que nos enfants
sur les bonnes bases qu'on leur donne
l'avenir est plein aux enfants ils
réussissent et qu'ils ont pas peur dans
les rues il a des grands frères et ils
allaient les petits cerfs les traditions
rurales et des petites ses petites
soeurs merci en tout cas d'avoir été
avec no mercy avec plaisir à ce point je
voulais parce que derrière il y aurait
il a commencé à parler
il est transmis le message qu'il a reçu
le soutien de tout le monde
toi de griezmann notamment exactement il
fallait voir sa tête quand je lui dis
que griezmann il a tweeté pour toi qui
es pembe que ils me posaient la question
il me dit mme bâ paix il n'arrive même
pas à prononcer le nom c'était tellement
touche en or mais c'est vraiment tout le
monde qu'ils ont qu'ils ont pensé
aziziya l'ancien franchement merci merci
j'espère qu'il va s'en sortir et
franchement si on espère vraiment
vraiment vraiment qu'il va s'en sortir
je voudrais vous remercier d'avoir été
là parce que ce témoignage n'est pas
facile à faire
et merci à vous deux d'être venu nous
voir et on espère vraiment qu'il va
aller mieux voilà et que vous allez
pouvoir sortir cette affaire et pouvoir
aussi voir la trouver dès qu'on va
pouvoir trouver les coupables
cette agression inadmissible